[Musique]
salut à tous aujourd'hui j'ai une
excellente nouvelle on est mercredi qu
est-ce qui a le mercredi le mercredi
c'est une journée pour le cinéma sa
rentrée c'est toujours le jour des
sorties ciné
et aujourd'hui exceptionnellement moi je
vais aussi vous offrir des films des
films en partenariat avec sony pictures
home entertainment
je vous fait gagner aujourd'hui 2 nous
ré et un dvd pour le film les 7
mercenaires un film avec denzel
washington
selon lui seulement comme j'ai pas et
blu ray les dvd ici pour l'instant je
vous le montre juste en affiche 16 films
moulin
alors qu'est ce que ça raconte les sept
mercenaires à les sept mercenaires c'est
l'histoire d'une petite ville aux états
unis on scrute qui est tenu par une
poigne de fer par l'industriel bartoloni
bugs et pour mettre fin au despotisme de
ce mec est juste insupportable
les habitants de la ville font appel à
des mercenaires et hors la loi pour lui
régler son compte
il engage exactement 7 hors la loi
chasseur de primes joueurs tueur j'en
passe et des meilleurs alors qu'il pense
vraiment s'engager un combat sans merci
avec cet homme ils se rendent compte
qu'il ya peut-être une autre cause
derrière et que c'est pas que pour
l'argent
c'est un film d'action c'est un film qui
est hyper sympa que je vous recommande
vivement
et comme je suis sympa et pas forcément
je vais vous les offrir je vous fait
gagner aujourd'hui deux blu ray et un
dvd
c'est cool pour les gagner c'est hyper
simple il suffit 2 1
tu ta bonne à la chaîne 2 tu mets un
pouce sur la vidéo les poussent vers le
haut bien sûr troisièmement tu commentes
en bas en m'expliquant va pourquoi tu
devrais gagner si tu veux gagner qui tue
veulent offrir quatrièmement tu partages
tu partages sans les réseaux sociaux que
ce soit facebook twitter instagram
snapshot interest google+ tu partages où
tu veux
le concours a lieu jusqu'au 15 février
et le 16 je vous dirai qui a gagné il y
aura trois gagnants de gagnant pour le
blu ray est un gagnant pour le dvd comme
ça vous verrez
zai washington pour les perdants ce
n'est pas grave vous pouvez quand même
vous le procurer parce que le film sort
aujourd'hui en blu ray dvd steelbook
collector 4k uhd chez sony pictures home
entertainment
abonnez vous leaké commenté partager ça
sera peut-être toi qui va la gagner
allez bon courage et si tu connais pas
le film et que tu as vraiment voulu en
savoir plus je te mets le lien dans la
description pour regarder la bande
annonce comme ça tu vas voir aux petits
oignons
je te laisse regarder bonne chance mon
courage et à demain